all right I call this the price ladder
so let's say you want to buy an iPad
right Apple gets you in the door with
the $330 cheapest iPad and you could
just get this one it's good enough for
98% of people but the second you want to
upgrade then Apple strategy is to walk
you as far up the ladder as they
possibly can there's always one that's
slightly shiny like you don't just want
the basic iPad with lightning today do
you okay well then you can get the
slightly better slightly newer one with
USB type-c that iPad is $449 should be
fine but annoyingly these only start at
64 gigs so you got to bump it up so now
you're looking at the storage upgrade
which gets you up to 256 gigs which
bumps you up to $5.99 but the iPad Air
is $599 but now that starts to 64 gig so
again bump that up now you're at 750 so
you how they just walked you up the
ladder from 330 all the way to
$700 that's mostly enabled by how much
they charge for Storage storage is cheap
but Apple charges a lot for those
storage upgrades